l'eau on ne la preuve on a vraiment la
preuve Brigitte Lavoie avait levé le
voile sur la maltraitance qui a vécu sa
soeur en septembre dernier alors qu'elle
était résidente au Floralies de la salle
elle n'était pas propre n'était pas lavé
après avoir été placé sous tutelle par
Québec l'enquête confirme les cas de
maltraitance et de négligence dans les
deux résidences des Floralies de la
salle et la Chine les conclusions de ce
rapport témoignent d'une situation
inacceptable marque de violence physique
de déshydratation chez plusieurs
résidents manquent d'équipements et de
personnel insalubrité gestion déficiente
rien ne fonctionnait dans ses
établissements pour aimer privé qui
appartiennent au groupe français Vivalto
depuis 2019 le rapport
parce qu'il y avait des centaines de
livres impossible pour la ministre
d'évaluer le nombre de victimes Québec
assure que depuis son arrivée à la tête
des résidences la situation améliorée
mais l'inquiétude chez les familles de
résidents demeurent
beaucoup changé sauf qu'ils vont partir
vraiment
au chsl10 ici elle
reste aucune sanction contre les
propriétaires des Floralies nées sur la
table pour le moment je pense que la
conséquence la vie actuellement de façon
quand même importante en fait il faut
comprendre que les résidences sont
actuellement en administration
provisoire des inspections surprises
l'embauche de personnel des formations
et une meilleure coordination font
partie des recommandations annoncées
mais la confiance s'effrite devant
l'histoire qui se répète
comme ça mais le problème c'était dans
l'implantation des mesures
les recommandations sont habituellement
communiqués mais ont réussi jamais à
toutes les implanter surtout que
l'enquête montre aussi que plusieurs
correctifs n'ont pas été apportées
malgré les visites répétées du ministère
ici Jacques Audrey Charbonneau
Radio-Canada Montréal